millennial a marketing buzzword kind of
like thought leader a millennial is
someone from Generation Y born between
1980 and 2000 roughly they're better
educated but make less than their
parents
they've got iPads and they've got debt
they also have dreams but the media
loves to trash-talk them so who are
these Millennials and what do they think
why not ask them are you guys
Millennials I've been told I fit into
the criteria yes yes yeah what is a
millennial
are you Eleni yes yes I'm on the tail
end of the generation I guess I'm 33 I'm
smack dab in the middle of that at 25
what did you watch when you like came
home from school as like a ten year old
Tiny Toons pinky in the brain you the
brain oh shoot like Rugrats and son are
you a table oh yeah I look so easy deli
toilet it was good for a period of time
what do you do now I have three jobs now
I am a middle school teacher I run a
non-profit I am a waitress and I'm a
freelance photographer what's your
retirement plan looking like oh shoot
don't even say that I had a retirement
plan in my career before opening the
store and now my retirement plan is
hanging on the wall you need like the
highest education to come even like
compete for like the bottom of the jobs
what do you say to the idea that
Millennials are in our
and some absorb it's definitely not true
well I spent a lot of time with 13 year
olds now and so I would say
comparatively we are not their statistic
and self-absorbed my world revolves
around me because I'm consistently in it
I'm a key player because if I wasn't I'd
be dead the whole idea of Millennials
being selfish it's not necessarily like
selfishness but it's about really
wanting to make some kind of impact and
kind of listen to our own desires
there's a lot that's broken in our
societies and a lot that needs to be
fixed and we have to do something about
it we're at the cutting edge of our
climate that's changing drastically and
we don't have time to wait I'm more
concerned about like social problems
like um racism and stuff like that are
you saying that you'd rather end racism
than have candy crush don't you just
want to have a house and be able to
watch your favorite sitcoms every night
that's not gratifying really there's so
many people I know we're older than
myself or like I have this I checked his
thoughts I did that and I'm miserable
I just want to have a home a wife two
kids just lay back that's it really want
do not want Wall Street what you don't
want don't want don't want no Obama what
one wants
a news media one don't want the
apocalypse don't worry
hahaha can you believe that it's like
we're already living it
you